- Fuck.
Fuck.
(groovy music)
- I feel like I'm a bit
of a jelly bean expert.
- I can definitely guess
black licorice, it's gross.
Here's the nose plug.
- It's literally just like
dissolving sugar in my mouth.
It doesn't taste like anything.
- Jelly, maybe bean flavored?
- No, I'm gonna say that
green, whatever green is.
- Ah, okay. Got it.
This one actually has a cinnamon-y taste.
- Can't even breathe out of it.
Oh. Whoa! (laughs)
A rush of flavor just came though.
Oh man, I hate black licorice.
I couldn't taste it at all,
but now that's all I taste.
- Probably look real silly right now.
- I can't smell it.
- Oh, shit.
- Apple?
- That's nuts!
They do taste very similar.
- This is white wine.
- So, white wine. (sniffs)
I took a wine tasting once.
You're supposed to swirl it.
- Smells a lot of white
wines I've had in my day.
Mama's had a lot of wine in her day.
- That's pretty good.
- Alright, this is a red.
Red's not usually my go-to.
- It's pretty good as well.
- I feel like I like this one
more, but I don't know why.
But this would go nice with a good meal.
- Feels earthy, heavy-bodied.
- The white wine.
- I like the white
better. It's fresh, crisp.
- Oh, no way.
Okay.
- Seriously? Are you sure?
Ooh, wow.
- Both of them did taste
really good. (laughs)
- I'm gonna try this one
in the white mug here.
- One.
- I feel like this one
does appear thicker.
- A little more bitter
than what I was expecting.
- The first one is slightly more bitter.
- This one tastes like hot chocolate, too.
It's less bitter than that one.
- I feel like that one's coffee,
and this one's an actual hot chocolate.
- I think I like the orange one
better, a little bit better.
If it was warmer, it would take the cake.
- But they don't taste the same.
Kate, you had to.
- The orange one's different.
- This is evil.
I don't believe you, this is not the same.
- No, I mixed them in a separate mug,
and then I poured a little into each one.
- But they don't taste the same.